well you know but all but twenty percent
of American children growing up in
poverty yeah that's pretty worried the
fact that we invest nothing in children
between the ages of zero and five at
least we have you know public our public
University of Berkeley is crumbling but
at least we have some investment in it
we do nothing for children between the
ages of zero and five and we seem to be
quite happy to have children growing up
in not not just poverty which wouldn't
be so bad but isolation lack of people
around the block of support a lack of
ability to go out and play in the dirt
you know those those kinds of those
kinds of things yeah that that
definitely has me worried late at night
babies are very resilient people are
very resilient we've managed to think of
lots and lots of different ways of
solving this fundamental human problem
of raising children but the fact that
babies and mothers of you know babies
can't vote and mothers are too damn busy
to vote or at least be involved in
politics means that the thing that is in
important literal senses the most
important thing for human beings which
is raising our next generation I think
this is literally true is something that
is just out there on the margins of
politics and I think that's really
problem